well
the first week ends for the
students of the
clark county school district however there is a lot of
frustration on the part of the
parents after a failure in the
kobe line of the district how are you greetings
cristián cáceres this page is a
resource used for the  district to
provide a current report of positive cases
in children and to verify the
status of their workforce some
people said wait in line for
hours if I know if it is solving
this problem on Friday night
the arrival of president joe
biden is expected  for the ceremony to be held
in memory of former senator from nevada
revivir this will be held this saturday
inside the mets on tour in
downtown las vegas former president barack
obama will also be present to
say goodbye some are expected
road closures around the site
while some will close tonight
near the airport today is the last
day of if  Originally it was going to
last until Saturday but they announced
that it would end on Friday as a security measure.
On this occasion, there were more than
a dozen companies that decided to
do it virtually, among them
are Microsoft and they will no longer move.
Remember that proof of
vaccination and  a mask to
attend the convention and we close with a
look at the temperatures we will have a
partly cloudy day with some
breezes around the valley but the weather
will be nice with highs in the 63
degrees we will stay that way for the rest
of the week I am cristian cásseres with
His previous Spanish indignation news
was on the day
[Music]